and were you going to have a space in
Trump and Trump almost gave you a
position or whenever he became president
wasn't there a talk of that and then it
kind of went away he just kind of went
into the into the wind with it well what
happened was he Con in 20
over the Christmas Vacation
um 2016 he's elected right and then
obviously the election isn't in November
so I was skiing and with my kids
in Colorado over Christmas vacation and
I got a call from his chief of staff
saying the president-elect wants to meet
that's so crazy and he wants to talk
about vaccines so uh you know I've been
an activist on trying to get safer
vaccines for a long time
and of course I agreed to me with them
so I went to immediately after getting
home I went to Washington or I went to
New York
and met with him in Trump Tower and
um during it was about a two-hour
meeting had you ever met with him before
I had sued him twice before successfully
yes and I had met him and you know the
the lawsuit
um was not something that had hurt our
relationship I stopped him from building
two golf courses in the New York City
watershed
about and those lawsuits were about two
or three years apart so
um and he knew me and he knew my family
he would um when my sister ran for the
for governor of Maryland he made a big
contribution to that he contributed to
my brother who was then
in Congress and I had a cousin who was a
congressman from Rhode Island and he
made contributions to that he was a big
Democratic donor at that point
he called me he asked me to come in I
had as I said about a two-hour meeting
with him at that meeting
people were coming in and out of that
meeting so
um so Steve Bannon was there
um Ren's previous if you remember him uh
I hope hill was there or kellyanne
Conway
and uh and Jared Kushner and both the
president's Sons at various times were
in that meeting people and he but I had
a lot of time alone with President Trump
too he
at that he believed that vaccines were
making people sick specifically he had
three women friends who were mothers one
who was in the building that day
who had perfectly healthy kids who had
gotten uh a you know their Wellness
visits
and they're around two years old and the
the children never went the same after
those visits they all had been
subsequently diagnosed with autism and
he believed that it was linked to the
vaccines
and he you know because he had been open
about that during the campaign hundreds
of women had as they did the same thing
that happened to me that got me into
this you know this career killing uh
um advocacy vaccine safety obviously
um
you know people start coming up to you
and saying you know this happened to me
this happened to myself and I had a
perfectly healthy child and
who exceeded all his milestones and I
took him in at 16 months and he you know
he was speaking he was toilet train he
had social interactions and I took him
in and he had a
a shot or a series of shots usually yeah
it could be up to nine yeah now he's
living in a tent at the circus right
afternoon and they at night a spike
fever 103 they have I mean the stories
were eerily all identical they had a
seizure and and over the next three
months they lose all of their capacity
to
or social interactions for eye contact
they begin yeah it's scary I mean a lot
of that stuff is super scary so but so
you go into that office I'll try to go
in there and he tells me these stories
and he says he wants to do something
about it and does it seem serious when
he's saying that like yeah he was dead
serious okay and he asked
um you know whether I would run a
vaccine safety commission then he asked
what I would do and I said
listen I don't think you have to do a
big political lift all I think you need
to do is open up the databases and allow
independent scientists in there to
actually look at the designs because
the hmos have all the vaccine data down
to batch for every child in America and
they also have the medical record so all
you have to do in fact you can do now
that is AI can do machine counting and
you can do cluster analysis
and you can figure out very very quickly
whether all of these epidemics not not
just of you know neurodevelopmental
diseases like all the add the ADHD the
speech like the tourettes and them the
um an arcolepsy the SD and autism oh
yeah the allergic diseases food
allergies peanut allergies oh it's crazy
when you think about it asthma and then
all the autoimmune adult asthma what
even adult asthma yeah
oh they but and they're all listed by
the way
on the vaccine inserts as vaccine side
effects because the only way that you
can see you know they pass this law in
1986
made it illegal to sue a vaccine company
for injury you still can sue them if
they know of any injury that's caused by
their vaccine and they don't list it on
the side effects 400 injuries falling
down the stairs everything well all the
autoimmune diseases but they're covering
all their bases that way yeah but
they're not allowed to list it
unless there are significant evidence
that it's actually being caused by the
vaccine FDA
FDA is not allowed to allow them to list
unless FDA believes is being caused by
the vaccine so so you have so so you
have this meeting with Trump just to
just kind of going back to that you have
this in the meeting with Trump and and
and you leave out of the meeting kind of
hopeful about it well I said to him what
do you want me to do and he said why
don't you don't announce it so a hard
question or escorted me to the Press
scrum how tall is Jerry Kushner you
think he's uh he's about I think he's
about my eyes he's about six one okay
and I think you're like six one too I'm
about a little over six I'm reaching I'm
doing yoga too I actually did some this
morning yeah well you start shrinking
too on you I mean I told you the next 20
years of your life are going to be a
nightmare because
um well you battle against it a lot I
see you at the gym all the time yeah you
used to yeah until it closed up but I
hear about you at the gym sometimes when
it opened back up briefly the trainer
that I have is like oh I saw uh Bobby
Kennedy in there the other day yeah I
was like yeah he's in there
um
um so you left out of there was it hope
oh yeah so then I went down and
announced it
talk to the press and then uh
a week later thighs earned made a
million dollar contribution to Trump's
inaugural
and then Trump comes in and we continue
to have some meetings without G and you
know that he he had set up that were
part of this process and we're rolling
to get this thing started actually seem
legit when you talk to him because he
seemed like somebody did he seem like uh
oh he's very very Charming but he's not
he's
listen fauci I'm about to publish a book
on fouchy yeah and he's
um
you know he's basically he's been there
for 50 years so he's like Jay Edgar
Hoover and the only way that you last at
that Agency for 50 years is by
carrying order for the pharmaceutical
industry and under his watch He's
supposed to prevent autoimmune and
allergic diseases
under his watch chronic disease has gone
from affecting 12 percent of the
American population to 54 percent we
take more pharmaceutical drugs than
anybody in the world as crazy as prices
he's made this country pharmaceutical
Nation yeah my brother's allergic to
Sesame seeds but you know exactly and
the way that you can allergies is from
the aluminum imagine in the vaccine
which is meant is put in that vaccine
to initiate an allergic response and it
and so if you have sesame seed oil is an
excipient in the vaccine or if you're if
you're eating sesame seeds when you have
that aluminum adjuvant in you
it can promote provoke an allergic a
permanent analogy
and if you look you don't know anybody
who is my age who has food allergies
very very hard to find I think it's one
in something like 1300 and today if
you're born after you'll have a football
team yeah everybody after 1989. so any
anybody who was born after 89 I think
it's one in 12 now oh it just went from
one in ten thousand in my generation to
one in every 34 kids and it's the same
with all these chronic diseases that are
all listed as side effects
so the proof seems to be right there
well that's correlation which isn't
actually proof but if you actually go
into the scientific literature
the proof is there but now is that
science so whenever you talk to Trump
you said okay let's open up this this
database right this information because
you said like yeah I said let's let's
you know I said you don't have to do any
heavy lift you don't have to go to
Congress
you don't have to change regulations all
you have to do is open up the vaccine
safety data language is the medical
records for the top nine hmos and allow
independent scientists to go in there
and just open it up so they can start
publishing and did he do it and no he
didn't it's still locked in a lockdown
don't even make sure nobody can get in
there
and you know even when Congress ordered
these two scientists called David
Michael Guyer awarded them to go in
there and they they let them into the
place they
they gave him one study room they would
not allow them to near a copy machine
they allowed them pencils and they had
to write down data and they they cranked
the heat in the room up to 105.
and they you know stole their hard
drives and they didn't want anybody in
that right and writing's hard to give
each other written a letter it's like
having a stroke the whole time it's like
I feel like it's insane you've written
something I mean it's absolutely yeah I
do right I mean you might still write I
mean it's yeah it's getting uh so anyway
so anyway so big foreign
and and Trump appoints Pharma uh
advisors lobbyists
and Eli Lily's Lobby is Alex Azar to run
HHS and as soon as they came and they
shut us down and was that a big were you
bummed about that was I bombed yeah I
was very bummed how to be a bombed yeah
of course it was like within our grasp
you know good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you could watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one
oh